what is going on there citizens the reject
Nation we're gonna watch House of the Dragon
episode 5 today John how's it going I'm great
and excited in all the things how are you I'm
doing well thank you for asking it's really kind
and courteous and and Regal of you to do ladies
and gentlemen leave a like for House Targaryen
also subscribe click the notification Bell to
get notified when the time Jump begins and full
length Reaction watch along as we sync up with
your own copy of House of the Dragon available
for our super sexual rejects over at our patreon
page it's a good page to be a part of last but
not least thank you to the team over at prepper
for helping us edit down these highlights
I think my glasses are ready to go let's go
rabbit dear you care for some
company I'd rather ride alone
according to you don't need no man
why does this feel so tense don't
get lit up with arrows any minute
he picked a really good Obi-Wan disguise
that's the wife what brings you to the
way more of it I'll have you at last
quite our marriage oh it's his actual wife what
will you do now will you strike the child down oh
sing whoa she had The High Ground
oh she paralyzed yeah
you cold-hearted bastard
I knew you couldn't finish
if you had not been so relentless in advance
you want to be hand to the king
these are all very valid points
Jesus this poor family The Grandmaster
delivered a tea to the princesses
tea yes that the grand maester
himself brought at the direct
I thought for Melos himself
my condition must be something very serious
What happiness it is to have been wrong hahaha
I would love it if he was
actually just sincere that
whole time I know didn't had
no cunning plan up his sleeve
princess
are you well
Damon's wife the lady Ria Royce has passed a
hunting mishap she was thrown from her horse
her neck and skull both crushed in the fall
and then a rock fell from the sky onto her face
God's will it wish to propose a
marriage between your son Selena
and my daughter an heir princess Rainier we would
like to know how the succession will be handled
can I presume that their children would
take their father's name you are not
proposing the Targaryen Dynasty end with
my daughter simply because she is a woman
what I want renero's children
she'll take their father's name
however it will be a hyphenate
first born ascends the iron throne
he or she will do so bearing the name
Targaryen this is an equitable compromise
it's gonna be the terrible father-in-law
I prefer roast duck to Goose
I cannot say why there are those who like us
very well I find it a bit greasy for my taste
you haven't had my cousin's Goose we perform
our duty to our fathers and to the realm
be fit open marriage that's right man
let's do it very modern so Progressive
for her time I'm sure Lena was already taken
with her she's grown quite calmly these last
few years you know his true nature nah
he's gonna fix him he will outgrow it
oh he's gay yeah the Rainer will be Queen of the
Seven Kingdoms and you will be her King consort
you wear your crown today
you'll need a sworn protector
but he still needs to Bear children yeah they're
gonna do their duty to their fathers and then you
know off with you I've heard you say that you are
to be married off at your at your father's whim
with no thought given to the yearning of your
own heart and now the day comes chosen for you
oh this guy's hurt man if there were another
path one that led to Freedom would you tread it
asking you yeah you gotta do it
man she won't but no there's no way
a marriage for love not for the crowd
I want that Crown though it is my duty to
marry a noble man from a great house and
Selena will make a fine husband and you
can be my squeeze I've gone to leave to
pursue his own interests Anna Tony's Grant to
be the same talk about the duck and the goose
my white cloak it is the only
thing I have to my [__] name oh
the Iron Throne looms larger than me
larger than anyone in my family so Kristin
wow choice and consequences
that poor guy yeah you could hear
his heart cracking during that pause
all identity is just shattered my
father received an accounting of
a lapse of morals does he know
about this rumor I don't think he do
not unaware that in flush of Youth there may
be errors made reaches in resolve breaches or
rather lapses happened to your grace no no no you
need to have a bit more clear in your sentences
my queen I was like wait my dude just wait my
oath has been broken no I have Dishonored myself
I deserve no consideration than David yeah
I would ask only this rather than gelding
me and having me tortured you would sentence
me massively to death wow you were the best
guy this is why text messaging friends exist
he's so much easier no idea what I just found out
the legion have always brought his grace relief
oh my God that arm I know it's disgusting
Oh I wanna I wanna appeal it
I have to have good
some might call that good fortune
it hardly makes a good song
is it no better to live in peace than
to have songs sung after you are dead
it depends another Lord might assure me
that I would rise like egg on the Conqueror
given the chance Grace that is your right it is
perhaps best not to know I feel so bad for her
the most steady decline of any character
I feel like shit's about to go down
yeah this is gonna be another red
wedding I don't think it's gonna be that
down a pinkish wedding congratulations
Your Grace you have made a fine match
for the princess thank you Lord Jason
what's Damon up to
uh she's put together Goose
right there oh here he is
even there to mourn the wife
oh my gosh smug bastard
we joined together in Celebration
tonight is only its beginning the honor
the crowd with House Targaryen and
oh no what's about to go down I feel
like viserys is gonna die tonight do
you know what color it glows when Old
Town calls its banners to warm green
huh congratulations what a blessing
this is for you stepdaughter
please be seated it sure is so
uncomfortable it's for the crest
it's my come Jesus moment writer
wedding between my daughter your future
Queen and Selena valarian air to drift
she's going to confront
her right yeah she's got to
or spill something out I feel
like something is gonna go down
this is the awkward glances
episode yeah I know foreign
oh my God everyone's just piecing
everything together by the looks
he's gonna be the one to do something
yeah there's gonna be somebody
answer for their crimes even targaryens who
are you sir Gerald Royce all the room's done
I don't even know who you are I am cousin
to your late lady wife ah yes terrible thing
positively bereft you know better
than anyone it was no accident were
you confessing some guilt so Gerald accusation
you know inking's Landing men are made to answer
for their Slanders even old prawns like you
don't talk to Peter Jackson like
that lady rear and I had no heirs as
her husband whatever she was she now passes to me
territory of runestone
after my niece's wedding I plan
to fly to the area and petition
Lady Jane myself perhaps I'll
see you there sir oh my God
fly to the area it's okay
buddy you gave it your all
is like the unspoken truths episode yeah
everyone just like knows what's really
going on he's not saying something
oh oh no oh oh God has anybody ever told you
your lady is pretty as your brother why are you
flatter me my friends oh sorry Terry about your
lady wife Debbie I wasn't no I have some time oh
you're so Christian called won't protect
them look at him the man is fully strong
I believe sir Kristen has bloodied that
white cloak of his with your bridesmaid
perhaps that is something with my remedy
oh my goodness she knows your
secret but now you know who's
guys leave Kristen alone this is a
terrible wedding he's been through enough
this is worse than the right way it's
more Awkward than the Red Wedding
in some ways more painful
watch we are both deeply invested in
this Union Selena was quite dead to me
as I know the princess is to you swear to
each other to God then and their secrets
because if those are kept safe is so real that's
a great shot with the two overlapping faces
something's building and I don't know what
yeah I'm getting like a panic attack vibe
there's too much attention to all this chaos
foreign
stop get you're in public
like this foot away at least
no no
what the [__] is happening
something else is going on
some Bag I'll have lanor
oh no yeah he got involved
oh no
yep
oh
my god wow foreign
to join Two Souls as one
here here we fired he's gonna
kill himself for the trees
on your mind foreign
oh my goodness I am yours in your mind the nor
of house Valerian reneur of House Targaryen
to be man and wife now and forever sir Kristen
wow I wasn't expecting that yeah
oh my God ah what a cursive day
imparted ending yeah
whoa
that's some rough stuff that's hardcore
what I would have paid to be a fly on that wall
way up high on that wall
I don't know who's winning
there's this some juicy in every corner when
are they gonna play you make me wanna shout
so it was missing really that's
the only thing oh yeah oh yeah
that was good that was fun was the King dead
I think the king might be dead especially
if we're about to time job be very surprised
if they wheel them in like I'm still kicking
but you never know I mean maybe
that'll be his thing maybe he'll be
cursed with long life and terrible terrible health
back here yeah
there had to have been a lot of people who
saw Damon put his hands on her face I feel
like there would have had to have been people
paying attention or someone nearby who's aware of
the allegation in this place that's really well
done build up because you're like shit's about
to go down and I'm not even sure what it is but
something terrible is about to happen from which
character is going to spark it up and I love that
too when [__] really does go down like it's it's
vague as to exactly what happens it just yeah
it just devolves into this chaos it was awkward
[__] I loved it yep tremendously cringe-worthy
filmmaking in a good in a in a good painful way
I was so impressed that episode because from just
a technical standpoint for writing because it at
first there was a part of me that was like okay
there's been a lot of like public knowledge that
that after this episode there's going to be
the time Jump that eventually happens where
um you know like some of our characters are
going to be replaced by other actors and such and
I was like okay some of this seems like this is
a setup episode for what's to come like they're
setting some stuff up and I I was kind of
worried that it was all that's all it was
mainly going to be with like a few like little
bits but it managed to be just a very in-depth
provocative episode again as you'd want that was
that felt so immediate and also did a wonderful
job successfully setting up the future like it did
both like simultaneously so well because there's
such a great groundwork laid for the future that
is off to just a terrible start like it's just
the worst start it wrecks the chess board and
then sets it back up for you yeah yeah and I
think that's really that's really impressive
uh that they did that because a lot of times
you know you often walk away with shows going you
know it's like a setup episode it's a good setup
episode and it's rare you can walk away going
it did both incredibly well like I'm actually
looking forward to seeing what the what the
future is uh and and what that time Jump will be
which I'm sad to see like the the Millie Alcott
alcaccia Alcock yeah who plays renera I'm I'm
so disheartened to see her go because again
delivering another Exquisite performance just just
a powerful one and such a such a turning point
episode for this character you know like that
scene that she has with Sir with uh Kristen on the
boat when he is proposing like why don't we just
Escape let's just like live our romantic lives out
and just be in love and forget this hierarchy this
thing you've always sort of dismissed and had had
issues with that you've always confided in me and
you're seeing how she's like obviously tempted to
a certain degree but she has to hide that because
this episode was so much about dealing with what's
going on underneath the surface something the
show has all done since the beginning this whole
episode especially the wedding that's what it just
was was like okay there's [__] building there's
ship percolating which is going to be the one that
tips over yeah which is the first thing that's
gonna really collapse it's gonna light the Powder
Keg and the main thing that got it going was uh
the thing that made it on board for us to me it
seems like Renee knew that he was probably gay
beforehand right which made her go like yeah I'll
marry him because I could do whatever I want yeah
yeah she's got too much knack for strategy not to
see the opportunity in that but the the ace and
the like the thing that she had to work with was
the fact that she he had a lover and so she and
now both of those have been just I mean I don't
know what's going to become a Christian and after
that moment with Alice with Allison I don't know
what Allison's plan is it seems like Allison's
now like she's in a Solo position I'm almost
cersei-esque almost just someone who's you're
like oh yeah she's Queen but now there's no king
with her yeah and now she has to worry about her
children what could be stripped from her in the
future yeah what could happen to her well-being
and maybe she needs to Harbor this information and
somehow use like you're like okay what's everyone
plotting now everyone's an enemy everyone's using
each other even more aggressively than they were
before all these bonds are even more tenuous now
and more yeah just like stress worn yeah I love
it it's great and then you got Damon who's just
waiting to cause all kinds of chaos just walks
in yeah every time he enters the room it's it's
solely to just cause the the most effective chaos
it's just funny how they like they kill off the
wife at the very beginning and that's their first
time meeting her right yeah and now we've heard
about her a bunch of times just solely from his
perspective where everyone's like she's fine and
he's like I hate that [__] and she shows up but
she's like compelling for those moments she's on
yeah just died because she was I thought oh it
was gonna be interesting to like unpack here
but again this show does a really good job like I
think that unspoken the unspoken truce theme they
had you know circulating throughout that whole
wedding is a big part of what the what the writing
kind of carries over throughout this whole show
because it weirdly like of course I would like to
have seen more with like it would just hit that
much harsh much more harsh if we had gotten to
know her a little bit yeah prior to that moment
but in that instance you get so much of the idea
of like her grasp on and her whole point of view
about Damon the marriage and it kind of seems like
she wanted a husband too you know in that little
moment she's sort of wanted an actual husband yeah
and and feels like like loads this man hates him
and also feels hurt to him betrayed by him yeah
it's like she actually might have wanted that and
I had to get stuck with you the worst version of
it who doesn't yeah who with whom I cannot enjoy
any of The Spoils of this position it's just oh
it's so cold and it's like what is Damon going
to be doing now and like what's the this this war
within the the crumbling targaryens is all with
it and it's so fun to watch it's fun it is it's
it's fun it's very messy yeah in a very sort of
uh Gallows kind of way and yeah like I that seemed
like even though that's not like a main plot
character that felt like one of those surprising
sort of Stark deaths where yeah you just meet this
person you kind of get that I loved that we spend
that little perspective build you you remarked
like why do I feel so uncomfortable just watching
her ride through this Valley and then she comes
upon Damon in the most like ominous but also like
oh okay it's just him kind of way but uh yeah I
don't know just like the it's such a cold scene
and it says so much about him in a way like it's
a bummer because yeah it's not really about her as
much as it is just like showing just the the the
depth of his is I don't know yeah just coldness
keeps coming back to mind because you can see a
way in which this Alliance could be beneficial
in some way shape or form but Damon doesn't seem
interested in any of that and when he comes back
around with um sir I can't remember his name Jaren
or whatever the other you know the relative of
hers like it's so painful to watch that guy
step up and to really feel like he's got an
opportunity to stick it to Damon only for Damon to
turn around and be like oh hey by the way I just
inherited your entire place of living your entire
Homeland you know can you arrange that for me yeah
like it's yeah it's just so it's Damon remains
this fascinating character because the more
it's a testament to Matt Smith's performance in
those moments because every time he's just sitting
there observing you're like what is this guy
thinking and there are little moments where you're
like yeah I can I can still see like a glimmer
of a human in there but so much of him is just
uh like a like a chaotic evil character like
a chaotic neutral character or something like
that where it's like I I could never really I
said this before and it rings true throughout
and and through this episode like it seems
like he almost never comes in with a plan
except to watch things twist
well I think he he always has
there's always a desire though behind his actions
there's always somewhat of a I think the the show
introduces him like he's a wild card you don't
know what this guy's gonna do he's just manic
he's the new he's Joffrey but more intelligent
you know but yeah with more tact but then uh you
know you quickly learn that no he's actually a
lot more clever and conniving because it's like
that you don't exactly know why he all they've
really showed us is that he doesn't like her and
then he kills her in the beginning of this episode
there's got to be a reason why but he died I don't
unless you like unless it's in the book unless you
really understand the politics already beforehand
where you're like oh [__] he killed her so that
means he's gonna inherit because they don't have a
hair like if you're my Heritage happen to know the
world that well but you really don't know why he
did that and then when you find out they're like
oh it's actually a really big political gain he
can have now but it's like why why that political
game because you can buy both versions you could
buy that he'd just be so cold is to be like no I
just hate her and I finally had an opportunity to
get her out of my way but then yeah you see the
bigger picture plan and it is like wow that is
smart and also your your choice to now resurface
that this event gives you the power that much more
in that situation as if it as it wouldn't have
done if you would like shown up to her funeral and
I actually do tend to read the top comments on on
these reactions that we do and I remembered that
there were people because we were talking about
the the when when they did fornicate Kristen and
renera and that people because we were like you
know it's interesting to see like a whole scene
of like debauchery and giving it to these sexual
pleasures and then you get a more of a tender
loving scene which I I think it was executed
that way but there were a couple of people who
were like I actually didn't find a tender at all
I thought it was like it was just a manipulation
of power that were narrowed it and and uh you
know also it broke his oath his vow and I kind
of forgot about that angle I I forgot about that
in admittedly I forgot about oh yeah that's right
they have part of chivalry is yeah I forgot all
about that and then to watch the effects come
into this episode and how much that has just
like he sleeps with her and it's been a little
bit of time he's like obviously madly in love
with her he's sacrificed his whole commitment
because of giving in to this um desire for her and
now he can't even have her and he's got to watch
her get married off and like you're just watching
this guys who is so Noble and honorable yeah it
just succumbed by the end just pulled down to the
bottom here or just annihilates this person at a
wedding who why exactly was it him do you think
that he murdered yeah like I'm like threatening
or did someone had a secret on that I I didn't I
didn't quite know it's like it does it's I'm not
here going why it just makes no sense at the same
time like I don't fully know why he he chose him
as a Target in the in the moment just the first
time watching it because I would like to go back
and revisit the scene the the way it sort of read
to me amid all that chaos was sort of that was the
last straw given that was the last interaction we
saw him have and that puts him in this precarious
new position of like oh yeah you know now I'm
part of this like apparatus of secrets and lies
and things and when everything breaks out I felt
like it was a almost like a proximity thing where
like they're both together or in close range of
each other and then maybe in all the chaos or
something like that it got to the point where it
seemed like one of them was attacking the other
one like I'm not sure because yeah when when
uh maybe he wanted to dissolve this whole thing
maybe I mean yeah maybe he just doesn't like I
I don't have to lie yeah I think either way what
happened I don't know exactly what got them in
you know whether Kristen was like I gotta find
you and kill you it seemed more like a random just
boiling over of yeah of his guilt and of his just
not wanting to be a part of this rig the regret
the guilt the pain of the conversation before
with renero where he yeah he lays out this very
pure Noble like let's run away together and just
have a life and all that stuff mounts and then
you know it's like Allison learns about this
and yeah it's like his his whole Spirit seems like
it's been demoralized and then yeah that exchange
with lenor's bow there uh it just seems like it
yeah it it just solidifies his descent into this
immoral place that I'm sure is eating in his soul
and yeah that's probably then just the target of
like I am overcome and I'm just letting it out on
you because that's exactly not what I want well at
the same time by letting it out on him though they
both now just they're married just married now and
they don't have the things they can have their
fun with yeah and it's like even if it was like
well you're you're still free to go out and you
know meet people and whatever it's like yeah that
that doesn't even probably appeal anymore because
they've both suffered such a yeah like a heart
loss well yeah I wasn't because you you there's
the show reading like clearly um re-explains it
that it's not just about going out and you know
getting all kinky and stuff and having multiple
lovers it's about being with the one you really
love yeah uh and now they don't get to be with
the one they really love I thought that was a good
use of that metaphor because at first you're like
thinks they're trying to say he's gay but I also
think it's just like yeah I know you love somebody
for real and so do I so yeah I thought that was a
good a well-articulated theme yes yeah very well
done stuff and uh so painful and then they just
skip all the celebrations and all the festivities
and they just go right to the wedding and you
just feel the that much more Hollow for everyone
involved they're just like they're barely looking
at each other and they're like talking all soft
and yeah you can just tell like what a horrible
night and then viserys heals over but I I love
the show for what it explores with this political
game and and the the the how these how when your
emotions just they they simmer they simmer when
you're rip you push it down for something that is
like Duty yet you see with the consequences of
that can be and and you're you watch something
like runera give in to sleeping with Kristen
and then how that's destroyed something you're
watching like renera who's been like such an
amazing character and he'd never Associated at
all it's like a bad person and then at the at the
climax of this wedding yeah you watch like just
the depravity of all these things that happen
because of things that she participated in or
part about part took and you know she's like that
whole divide with Allison at the end which is like
Allison's just finding out the truth everything
with Kristen Damon even like Damon's just all
over the place here he's like freaking trying to
sleep with the one girl or like tempting her and
then he's like I won't remember just want this God
damn it yeah anyway so yeah that that situation at
hand and then of course now he she chose him um
what's the name again uh the the Valerian yeah
uh Lenor Leonor she chose she chose Lane ore yeah
specifically she was given a choice chose him and
through that choice now led to Leonor losing the
one he loves it's just like this major collapse
all the surrounding things that not not solely her
obviously there's a whole bunch of other players
involved here but it is cool to see how it's from
She's the central point of it all you know uh it's
it's just it's just gnarly [__] oh yeah and
it's like the such a web of consequences comes
out of of what in that episode feels like such
an intimate isolated you know heat of a moment
and uh and two I love the way this episode reveled
in especially once you get to the ceremony in this
quality and it's throughout both Game of Thrones
and this this sort of propping up of customs and
of appearances despite the fact that everyone in
the room practically is side eyeing each other and
knows at least a version of what's really going
on here and knows that this is kind of a sham
and yet we're all kind of here to make face and
to you know enjoy celebrating and being watched
but like when the chaos breaks out you can feel
that tension that lives underneath and it makes
for a good sort of just audio visual metaphor
for the struggle between order and statecraft
and just the base human instincts yeah and that
something like this that is based on base human
instincts that is about attraction and and you
know arousal has led to all of not every part of
this but so much of the conflict that boils over
here there's also this other quality that this
episode really like what I think Game of Thrones
is generally explored and this show especially of
you know like something as simple as listening to
your heart's desires and just being appreciative
of what you have versus this Chase for legacy
yeah and then you watch as the king who did
you know pretty much take the more pacifist
route has made some questionable choices that
could have dire consequences for the future
of Targaryen for the House Targaryen which
will obviously um it's already begun it's it's
already begun and yet on his last day she's like
lamenting and like just so sorrowful he's just
weak doesn't have he's not even with his Queen
for like most of his the most of the time yeah
he's not even with her her absence is large
exactly yeah it looms very large and green dress
and he's there wondering like what well people
even remember me like I'm nothing you know
yeah and did I do the right thing by trying
to keep peace and then it's interesting how all
he wanted to do was try to keep peace and by the
by trying to keep peace he is now set up for the
future generation to pretty much help it crumble
yeah yeah you know which is which yeah it always
reminds me of the time machines that whole thing
about like the more you try to to avoid an outcome
you'll you'll just kind of Bring It about uh and
yeah like I thought that was such a wonderfully
like again hats off to Patty considine because
like it's such an intimate moment and I thought
part of me was like maybe he's just gonna die
right now yeah um but yeah like and and that is
interesting to see contrasted between the two of
them because they're both in some ways kind of
pondering that and the sort of like what this
duty of of you know being the king or the queen
does to you and it's like he's sitting here going
you know I had a pretty good life but yeah did
I did I not you know risk enough you know for
greatness and then you have renera who's in this
position of like yeah given an offer to throw all
that away and you can see still despite how much
she kind of thrusts all this stuff off that she
does have like a taste for this life and and
not wanting to so easily leave it behind and
I felt like her rebuke of Kristen there was more
confident than just like no no I got duties and
stuff it's like no I intend to rule you know and
then you watch that contrast in viserys who seems
like he truly would have been better off not being
in this position just living life and giving of
you know the natural gifts that are so apparent
in him as a character and yet don't really serve
his role as king very well and Lead his counsel to
constantly be trying to manipulate him and stuff
and uh and two just poor poor old Auto
Hightower you got him for a half a second here
I mean it's saying goodbye I wonder if it was
interesting I kind of like flips the perspective
in a moment yeah when you're like man you were
pretty manipulative you definitely wanted your
own personal power gain I mean and you did use
your daughter but you're also making some really
solid points right now back and forth and it's
like yeah I mean a fair point I'm so caught up
with all the messed up things you were doing I
wasn't really thinking about like oh yeah you
know it probably would be my my might proceed much
more smoothly yeah I mean they both have points
there although I did have to be like as much as
it's like well you know if you hadn't given renira
that shadow of a doubt Queen but I'm at the same
time I'm like you put her in this position and you
gave her this thankless job yeah of having to be a
baby machine you know to push your ultimate agenda
get aegon on the throne but it's harsh stuff
but now we've got a lot of different characters
um coming up here and there's a
it's a hell of a world uh yeah
it's it's so engrossing it's you're just
funny that opening shot was like this is the
I like the last episode Lord of the
Rings quite a bit um the rings of
Power episode four I liked it quite a bit
but the opening shot just made me just go
I didn't I was waiting I was reserving it was
that this is like the definition of anti-lord of
the Rings it is because that opening shot is the
most like Peter opening sequence of her writing
yeah the amount of different like sweeping shots
they kept using is the most like Lord of the Rings
but importance but it doesn't feel like Sweeping
in wondrous and glorious it feels like cold and
tension and oh my God something terrible is about
to happen and it's quiet yeah and then instead of
something particularly dramatic to punctuate it
it's just a really Stark unpleasant death for that
character who just got that cinematic treatment
yeah yeah so it's it's it did feel like I don't
think this show in any way is trying to like make
that statement at all um it's just something that
went off in my own subconscious no there's a
there's a lot of interesting contrast I think to
to make between these shows honestly because there
are so many similarities in terms of how they're
produced and in terms of what the material is to
some extent but yeah one is is very much more sort
of characters where they're intense on the surface
and are very focused on those whereas the other
one is like people have their surface intense but
it's all about what's underneath all that and what
is unsaid or said in Whispers And it's all a mess
it's all kind of hard to understand and hard to
pinpoint who is really is there a moral good well
I mean you watch as their souls become corrupted
because they keep sacrificing things because of
we gotta keep things in order because of monarchy
peace we're going to keep the peace but also have
wars in the right places yeah you just watch as
these as everyone's Souls like deteriorate as
a harsh World it really because like everybody
now like and that's the thing that this season
I think has been a special like Game of Thrones
across the board but this season has taken more
I think this so far has had more characters that
you could just outwardly directly sympathize with
from the get-go and I feel like part of Game of
Thrones was telling you like those people will
not make it very far in this world and this one
is showing you those people but then subject to
the transformations to those like sir Kristen is
such a good guy after today I wonder what that
character will be yeah I mean I I think this
show really does I see a lot of people who are
already like quick to say like to show so much
better thinking like I see a lot of people who
say that like it's better than Game of Thrones
and of course there's there's undoubtedly like so
many similarities undoubtedly but at the same time
it's such a different show it's it's very very
different like you kind of check in with just
the same few people every episode in this show
and it's and the way they handle time and the way
they're handling this buildup and what the main
objective is because it's like it gets you focused
on yeah it's all about uh ultimately ending on the
consequences of who's gonna be you know sitting
on the Iron Throne sure that's but it it's not as
big of a chessboard ignores it and Game of Thrones
kind of kicks off a little faster into a little
bit more of that exciting I think I think they're
just very different I think I think the way they
they make you feel is very different yeah and
um and so I I think these are I don't know there's
a lot about what I've experienced with these five
episodes so far that I I do find a little bit I
do prefer but I generally don't sit here and come
I don't ever really take the time to compare and
go which one do I like more hey there just hasn't
been enough time and and B they're they're very
different yeah and like I could just enjoy both
you know same I've done that with like better
of a call so I'm breaking bad like I haven't
I haven't bothered to ask myself like which one
and let me just try to really figure this out
because I'm like no yeah they're similarities
but they're different and and I think they just
kind of work together you know so that's I think
to me that's ideal that's how it should but the
production on this sounds like chaos for like the
showrunner like I'm no I'm not coming back or one
of them leaving early I wonder if they knew that I
I guess I've fallen I'm curious because yeah like
you don't want to hear three or four episodes in
like you're losing one of your show Runners but
part of me wonders if knowing the response to you
know they know the response to the end of Game of
Thrones and so I bet they were like we need as
many of those hands on deck to get this ship
sailing and then after a first season we could
we could mix it up a little bit because I think
they have Alan Taylor coming in instead who's
also done a ton of Game of Thrones and has done
good work on Game of Thrones and so in that way I
it almost seemed like that could be just the plan
all along he's like I'll come back for a season
but it could be chaos I'm not sure honestly it
seemed like a lot of people were surprised on
the cast so maybe not but I don't know here's
hoping it doesn't dip it I mean it looks like
this would be let's look at this looks like it
could be a toll to put together even if it's not
chaos I could imagine that if you're trying to
put one of these things together that was the
thing about Benny often why is as much as I'm
like you guys did not handle this the right way
I was also like but spending like 10 plus years
doing this seems like it would take a lot it
would Age you way more than that yeah it does
seem like an incredible undertaking to to you know
guide a ship like this I mean I wasn't even that I
wasn't even interested in the show I wasn't either
when I was announced you know I was like who's who
cares when it was announced and then there were
a couple trailers came out I'm like I'm not I
don't even want to react to it like now that one
seems excited yeah I saw that people were getting
excited they were they were loving the trailers
and and I did I wasn't I just wasn't interested
um and then I'm like wow this is the best
thing on TV right now I feel like it was
the last thing on anybody's Minds that it
could be such that they would just return us
to what feels kind of like the Heyday of Good
Game of Thrones yeah it was so much more than
that yeah but but yeah that's what's been
so rewarding is it's like oh dang already
the storytelling is the richness I remember it
and it has the sort of core sensibilities that
made those you know particularly beloved
Seasons so good but yeah it is doing
a thing of its own that matches this world but
feels unique and distinct and yeah I feel like
you could come out of this preferring one to the
other but also you know I feel like I I'm kind of
in a similar Camp as you I'm like I don't really
feel the need because yeah I would put them on for
slightly different reasons you know if I'm in the
mood for this world well I think also even though
there's dragons in here that's such kind of an
accepted part of typical fantasy that you're they
just kind of feel like an animal it's another
animal and the way they fuse them in here too
whereas I remember Game of Thrones opening scene
dealt with the white walkers right away yeah and
it was such a like horror Fantastical element that
sets the stage for something that will lean more
into fantasy you know yeah and this this seems
more and granted like they did that in the opening
and it was like pretty much just very real for a
while yeah yeah and but this this seems to just be
really focused it's it's more um what's the word
more contained and and uh it feels more real like
if there weren't dragons people might question
like this is a real historical is it based on
actual writing it's actually half actual Mysteries
of the time yeah well and two I like that they you
have we've had a couple of dragon set pieces that
are you know big CG set pieces but like in this
episode even like the dragons show up in like
one transitional moment and you see that they're
around and I think that contributes to that it's
like they don't have to be the focus half the time
and you don't need every episode to have some
kind of crazy Dragon sequence they just remind
you that they're there sometimes and I feel like
that often lends more Credence than a big dragon
that you've seen uh because yeah they're good at
selling this fantasy as not too distant fantasy
and without the white walkers it feels that much
more grounded I think that's the thing with the
with Game of Thrones that really distinguishes it
for me is this feels like a historical political
show yeah whereas Game of Thrones I felt was was
that but also I I would throw in the word fantasy
all the time because you had soothsayers and
you had people like resurrecting the dead and
you had the White Walkers and there was there was
a bigger sense of like there's magic in this realm
yeah and I don't really ever say the word fantasy
with the house of the Dragon yeah no I mean they
haven't I'm trying to think like they have their
elixirs and things like that but so far we haven't
really met any characters who are mystical so to
speak yeah it's the only really mystical element
thus far is the dragon and even Eve dragons and
even things like the Gods like I remember Game
of Thrones having more of a sense of like like
God's really out there whereas this more feels
like religion feels you know in real life where
it's just like yeah it's what we believe in and
sure you know you think they're out there but
I don't get the sense that they might actually
intervene at any point in time right right
yeah well guys Ah that's a great episode it's
a good ass show Let's uh catch up soon can't
wait for next week let's see what's going on
subscribe click that Bell leave a like thanks
to all support us on patreon and some sort of
Mikhail Lyndon McHale we have looked up your
name on Urban Dictionary you're gonna like it
and here's what we found the sexiest man alive
that is how we have always described Mikhail
always he is the perfect exciting handsome and
is known to have a huge you know what oh man
put it away it is so big it gets in the way it
gets trapped bigger doors when you try to close
it down on your way to driving he is dominant
over his brothers he with with that huge thing
of his just uses it to show I'm the only one
gifted with this and will [__] on anyone who
opposes him you don't want to mess with this guy
learn that the hard way he's got a third wheel on
himself weapon kickstand bruh he will [__] on
them overall the most amazing guy yeah man not
afraid to lay down the law and if anybody
questions all you got to do is whip it out
Chase I mean Michael McHale who you have we're so
big D energy by your bde big D energy and uh you
are ultimate Alpha you are in our lives Mikhail
thank you for being you this is for you no wonder
you love James Bond because you got so much in
common with that hey dude you're the next one